all right it looks like we're now live
for our monthly political theory
and practice discussion so
i picked out something that that comes
up every once in a while
in contemporary politics and we could
say
in the culture of war um and it's
you know so i'll just put it on the
table it's uh
the grand inquisitor chapter
and is that
any simplistic treatment of the
grand inquisitor chapter like any other
great piece
of classic literature is going to be
off base and wrong and probably stand in
the way
of actually understanding what's going
on
and what's being said in that there is
no simple
application of the grand inquisitor
chapter so anybody who tells you that
there is
is either poorly informed
or not a very good reader or is trying
to sell you some lines some sort of
ideology
and i think that it would be good to
talk about some of the
central features of this and then some
of the uses that people have made
of it and then what we can actually make
of the big themes in the grand
inquisitor
so you know it's in it's in the context
of this
book the brothers karamazov which is a
great piece of literature we're not
going to talk about the brothers
karamazov
per se um you know there's lots of other
interesting things going on in the book
but i don't particularly
care that much about them as far as this
discussion goes
um just of course an ama where we go all
over the map
talk about all sorts of other things in
philosophy as well
we're going to talk about this this
chapter in particular
so ivan is back in town and he's talking
with his younger brother alyosha
who is essentially preparing himself for
the monastic life
ivan is you know essentially
an unbeliever but he's an unbeliever uh
in christianity in in the sense that
um not of like you know a dogmatic
atheist
who says oh this is all mythology this
can't possibly be true if you read the
previous
chapter rebellion it's rather that he's
got a beef with god
and the kind of the kind of
rule then the kind of human society that
god allows to be
set up and to victimize so many people
and so he comes up with this thing that
he calls a poem
i'm actually going to read bits and
pieces of this to you and then we can we
can comment on them and discuss them
so he says my action takes place in the
16th century back then by the way
you must have learned this in school it
was customary and poetic works to bring
higher powers down to earth and that's
that's what ivan is doing he's bringing
christ
back to earth and he says okay so i've
got my own little
poem i'm skipping ahead a little bit um
here we go so christ desired to appear
to his people if only for a moment to
his tormented suffering people rank with
sin
but loving him like children this is the
time of the inquisition
in spain and he says that um he appeared
inconspicuously but strange to say
everyone recognized him this could be
one of the best passages in the poem and
and i'm going to point this out
so um ivan you know we
we normally talk about breaking the
fourth wall when it comes to
like television or film or a character
like turns to you and says
can you believe this crap you know or
you know and then i was doing
this or things like that that's
happening
with ivan as he is presenting to
alyosha and as dostoyevsky through ivan
is presenting to us the readers
this poem this this uh literary work
that is not written down
except in dostoyevsky it's not written
down by ivan
ivan is commenting on it every so often
and he
and alyosha will chitter chat back and
forth about it so this is the first
place where he brings it up he says um
why is it exactly they recognize him
people are drawn to him by an invincible
force they flock to him surround him
follow him
he passes silently among them with a
quiet smile of infinite compassion
the son of love shines in his heart rays
of light enlightenment and power stream
from his eyes so
very miraculous stuff right going on and
then he
he does a miracle he he brings a dead
girl back to life
and the grand inquisitor is like all
right we're going to put an end to this
stuff
and so he has him arrested and then
in his cell there's this confrontation
and this confrontation
is what takes up the bulk of the
chapter and this confrontation which is
entirely
you know put in the mouth of the grand
inquisitor
with ivan and alyosha every once in a
while saying something
sort of stepping out of frame is going
to be the grand inquisitor
presenting a case essentially against
christ and the freedom that he was to
bring but
here's where we get political
implications for it um
especially if you think about politics
not just in terms of elections and stuff
like that
or as a particular discipline but in a
very broad sense is that with
which determines a lot of human
existence through culture society
uh organization all of that so
we wind up um
uh seeing the the grand inquisitor
telling christ
you don't belong here anymore um
you shouldn't you shouldn't have come
and i'm going to tell you why we have
effectively replaced you
since people are chiming in at this
point i want to make sure that i
echo something that i said at the
beginning no simple interpretation of
the grand inquisitor chapter is a good
interpretation
it's a complex piece of literature and
anybody who tries to sell us it's just
about this
just about this is basically either you
know
deluded or selling us a line or
something like that it's a rich
piece of classic literature with many
different important facets to it that we
can
get into so in any case the grand
inquisitor coming back to the the actual
story right i'm going to read a little
passage
this is uh um this is i've been talking
to alyosha he says
the grand inquisitor lays it to his and
his colleagues credit that they have
finally
overcome freedom this is the grand theme
that often gets picked up on
people like oh this is all about you
know uh overcoming freedom and
oppressive totalitarian societies
that again that's a simple-minded
approach to it there's more going on
here
and so ivan says they've finally
overcome freedom and have done so in
order to make people
happy for only now has it become
possible for the first time to think
about human happiness man was made a
rebel
how can rebels be happy that is a
central problematic about this and the
grand inquisitor
later on in the story tells christ that
listen you came and you didn't do the
things that you should have done
in order to make human beings happy
instead you gave them this freedom
that they already had but you sort of
intensified that freedom
and you in in effect did things that
worked out good for the strong
but made the rest of humanity unhappy as
a result
we're here to fix that and the grand
inquisitor presents
himself as uh he talks about the strong
at two different points there's the
strong who are like
all this this you know religious
[ __ ] that we're gonna put it aside
that's one kind of strong and then
there's the strong who are like
well we could use this and finally bring
about
something like not even a utopia on
earth but
something better than this crap
that we're cyclically going through all
the time
with you know rich people dominating
things or the powerful in the sense of
the politically powerful
running things and not knowing what
they're doing you know
as ivan says the grand inquisitor joins
the intelligent people the
the elites who actually are not
just saying let's let's screw everybody
over get everything for ourselves
they're like
wow things are messed up human beings
are making a bad use of their freedom
we we need to fix this and we can fix
this so that is the fundamental
conflict there what really centers the
piece
is the biblical story in you know
matthew in particular of the three
temptations
and so um
here we go the dread and intelligent
spirit the spirit of self-destruction
and non-being the great spirit spoke to
you in the wilderness this is the grand
inquisitor speaking to
christ and it has been passed on in
books
to us that he supposedly tempted you did
he
really and was it possible to say
anything more true than what he
proclaimed to you
in his three questions so here we get to
the the real center piece of
the chapter um and he says this is the
grand inquisitor
if a real thundering miracle was was
performed on earth it was on that day
the day of those three
temptations so what are those three
temptations
um christ has been fasting out in the
desert for 40 days
and the devil comes in and says why
don't you take those
stones over there and turn them into
loaves of bread you look pretty hungry
guy
and christ says you know each each time
he responds with a
passage from scripture man is not lived
by bread alone you've all heard that
phrase right
and the grand inquisitor saying actually
they do live by bread alone and meat and
all this other stuff
all these other creature comforts so
that's that's one of the temptations
then a number one uh there's another one
of the
temptations is um a temptation to
a kind of kind of pride
a kind of you know checking to see
whether you really are the favorite of
god you know jump from this high
point you know on on the top of the
temple
the angels will catch you and and christ
says don't tempt god
and then the third temptation is the
temptation of power the devil says
see all these kingdoms of the earth i
will give you dominion
over all of these and all you have to do
is like say you know
essentially like be my second in command
bow down to me
and in the biblical narrative christ
rejects these
in the grand inquisitor's narrative
christ
screwed up by rejecting these and not
taking
the power that was being offered to him
whether by the devil or just by his
own nature which would have resulted in
making human beings happy
and and what you know what is that well
he he says
let's think about uh bread right
you want to enter the world you're going
empty-handed with some promise of
freedom which they
human beings and their simplicity and
innate lawlessness cannot even
comprehend
which they dread and fear nothing has
ever been more insufferable for man and
for human society than freedom
see these stones turn them into bread
mankind will run after you like sheep
grateful and obedient
you didn't want to deprive human beings
of
freedom and you rejected the offer so
what kind of freedom you reasoned if
obedience is bought with loaves of
bread he says you objected that man does
not live by bread alone but you do know
that in the name of this very earthly
bread the spirit of the earth will rise
against you and fight with you and
defeat you
and everyone will follow him exclaiming
who can compare to this beast where he's
given us fire from heaven
and if you think about you know not just
bread but all the other material
circumstances that people are are
lacking
there's something to this right um it's
not as if this is just you know a stupid
grand inquisitor who doesn't understand
human nature he understands human nature
quite well people are moved by material
considerations
then he moves on to the next challenge
the next temptation which is that
of miracles do a miracle and people will
buy into miracle authority superstition
all of this can be used to
provide people not just with something
to believe in but something to
feel confident about something to
center themselves with and you know
again this to provide these sorts of
things
um would impinge upon human freedom
and dostoyevsky's ivan is positioning
christ is coming to expand human freedom
uh whereas the grand inquisitor is
willing to get people to use their
freedom
to throw that freedom at their feet so
they can have a better
organized society and this brings us to
the third temptation
that of power that of being able to
you know finally make things work right
and what that requires is everybody to
be part of
one big whatever we want to call it
community conglomerate
um everyone to be on the same page
everybody to
worship the same things or a range of
things to be
part of a society in which
you know things are organized
and you know if you think about the uses
of human freedom
that lead people to you know want that
these are we see this in every society
right there's always jackasses that are
doing stupid things with their freedom
that you know somebody comes along and
says there ought to be a law they ought
to be punished or we ought to take care
of that sort of thing
um and and we live in societies in which
in some respect things are incredibly
organized
and in other things are incredibly
anarchic where we're made prey to each
other
the grand inquisitor is telling christ
buddy you screwed up you could have you
had the power
to do all these things to organize not
just
a society but the whole world to
give people things to believe in to
provide them with all the material
comforts
you screwed up so we're going to do that
and that's going to require
that the masses and
even you know some of the elites who
think that they're you know uh
running the show but aren't really
running the show to
lose their freedom to give up their
freedom and we will exercise our freedom
with this heavy burden of managing
human life so that is the and that's the
story right and
there's some more stuff at the end where
you know like
of course you know the christ kisses the
great inquisitor and then
is gone and then uh alyosha kisses
ivan we could talk about all that that
symbolism later but
this is the real crux of it these three
temptations
this drive to provides to use
freedom to curb freedom uh because of
freedom's
you could say anarchic and um
rebellious tendencies among human beings
all of which you know seems to be quite
accurate
uh not only in dostoevsky's time but in
our time and in previous times
um now what do we make of this
politically when does this this grand
inquisitor
chapter get invoked well oftentimes
in terms of totalitarianism or
totalizing tendencies
but i think that it is of wider
application
i think that you could apply this even
to those who
are you know paragons
or champions of a certain kind of
freedom freedom
understood in certain ways isn't
necessarily
the freedom that that in this story
christ came to bring it can be a very
selfish freedom it can be
a you need to get your own man and
and screw everybody else kind of freedom
and that can be just as much the product
of an ideology
and a power structure as what the grand
inquisitor is putting out
so we'll come back to this i'm going to
take some of the questions that people
have here uh cola moose points out
hannah rent talks about this in
connection with billy budd and on
revolution
great you know i mean there's lots and
lots and lots of people talking about
the grand inquisitor
what we want to put on the table is not
just whether somebody talks about it
what
do they actually have to say
about this enigmatic poem
of ivan karamazov
uh giga chad mesh
how do you approach dostoevsky in the
classroom when there's more emphasis on
critical thinking and liberal
capitalist pedagogy i don't know where
you're getting this stuff from
if you think that there's something
called liberal capitalist pedagogy
and it's like a thing that that is
widespread in the classroom
a piece of fiction like like this uh
surely there's
meditation on psychology faith and
suffering instead
i mean i have never encountered any
problem teaching
any of the texts that i want to teach in
my over 20 years of teaching in a
variety of different settings
teaching quite controversial stuff and i
also teach critical thinking as well
which i think is a good thing um
so i i don't even know what to make of
that how do i teach dostoevsky
i go in and i teach it i mean it depends
on what class we're doing
he's usually coming up in an
existentialism class
but we could we could certainly do it if
i had the chance to teach a political
theory class i probably would
use this this passage um
all right mark is is here uh rheya says
it's going good
uh some back and forth stuff there um
reya says that it's their dream to be a
philosophy professor
so that's that's a tough one uh you know
a little bit of a digression here
you know i think all of you know that
the job market
for philosophy and the humanities
to be a professor is pretty bad
worldwide right i mean it's not as if
there are a lot of jobs
in in europe although they just sort of
keep chugging along doing what they do
and there have been lots and lots of
cutbacks and shifts away from
having tenured professors to
you know more and more outsourcing to
adjuncts
in america and also in to to some degree
in britain
you know and i think this is starting to
affect other places
as well um so you know
let's come back to some of the themes
that we could we could talk about coming
from this
what would it take to actually have
professors um you know
as a secure class i mean not not
necessarily that everybody who's a
professor
deserves that i mean a lot of them are
talking about my peers they're kind of a
mixed
lot aren't they some of them are good
and some of them are not so good
but would we have to have a new
organization
of society in order to make that work
and would that require something like
what the
grand inquisitor is proposing people
giving up
some freedom in order to realize
some some other value um
in the the kind of workplace that we're
in
where is the freedom who has the freedom
that's the question to ask
i mean going back to the question
earlier about
you know teaching dostoevsky and
critical thinking and liberal capitalist
pedagogy
okay so some people actually do run into
problems in the classroom
uh and in their institutions not
typically from liberal
you know from liberal capitalist
pedagogy but more often from
uh like saying things that conservatives
don't like if you're in a particularly
conservative area
and people can write letters or emails
to
you know the uh trustees or people like
that who by the way are usually
just business types and administrators
are usually just business types these
days
or you know it could be that you're one
of those lone conservatives who's
getting persecuted by
the you know the the far left in in the
academy which
happens much less you know frequently
than people would you know like you to
believe
um or it could be that you've done other
things
very often there's a lot of there's
discrimination that happens
on the basis of um gender
race or things like that and then
there's always the bad
actors who are you know um engaging in
you know sexual harassment and getting
away with it for years and years
and you know departments covered up or
just you know
doing other things that are less
damaging but equally venial
um and so there's lots of ways to be
unfree in academia
i would tell you that actually from the
perspective of somebody who has
not just adjuncted but knows a lot of
other people
who have been struggling for years and
years to get a tenure track position
oftentimes without
ever succeeding in it that the unfreedom
is
primarily economic not knowing what
classes you're going to teach next
semester or whether you're actually
going to get classes or that whether
your classes are going to get poached
by full-time people taking them
that that makes for a rough life i've
seen people ground down
by going from one to two year
appointments to one to two year
appointment moving themselves across the
country
for a decade and then finally just
burning out you know
so what would it take what sort of
reconfiguration of society would we have
to do
in order to keep the people who have the
freedom
from exercising it in crappy ways that
deny everybody else the exercise of
their freedom
we would have to have something like a
system and we don't have an educational
system in place
uh there is there is the united states
has over
2000 colleges and universities some of
which may be parts of a state system but
each of which is its own little universe
morally and fiscally speaking
and politically speaking so
all right colomous says a rent compares
the christ character with billy budd as
people who transcend
either virtue or law i don't remember
which
um yeah i guess i mean that's sort of
like what deleuze's take is
and um he's got this great essay that i
did some videos on
um called bartleby or the formula
and he's he's saying that they don't
transcend the law actually like billy
budd gets caught up within the law
right and it's um
it's the master at arms who is the
character who evades the law altogether
um all right i'm not sure what this this
references to
chugging along treading water more from
what i hear from my mate
i'm not sure what i said that about
before but
all right um
okay so here's an interesting thing by
by waterby it's great
professor sandler is studying these
classics
many many people are doing this there's
lots of people engaging with dostoevsky
or plato or any of those people
sometimes it feels like appreciation for
these ways of thinking has disappeared
so that's a local problem um and we're
fortunate that we live
in this era of the internet you know in
the past like when i was
a college student if you were on a
campus where most of the people were
kind of
you know just partiers and rum-dums and
not particularly interested
in uh reading great literature and
talking about it which wasn't entirely
the case
well you'd have to go somewhere to find
that right you'd have to find some
community elsewhere it might
be at i don't know like a coffee shop or
maybe you'd have to come down
from sheboygan down here to milwaukee
and try to find something
now if you if you want to find people
who are interested in
talking about dostoyevsky all you got to
do is put it into like google
and you know dostoyevsky local group
book club meetup and you're going to
find something so
it might not be good any more than any
other group is going to necessarily be
good
but we're actually quite fortunate in
that we have this
massively interconnected world you know
mark smith who's here
is from south africa he and i have been
corresponding
for years and years and you know meeting
up uh
through video conferencing quite a bit
and talking about
aristotle and arendt and dos well
sometimes dostoevsky and sometimes other
people that just would not have been
possible
you know back when i was a college
student
i mean we could we could correspond
maybe through
uh writing letters to each other and who
knows how long that would take
or making super expensive phone calls
but um you know we
we are really quite quite fortunate so
i'm glad that you
like that i and others are spreading
these classics but
i don't think that appreciation for
these ways of thinking has disappeared
as a matter of fact
i would say that there's there's more of
that
evidence at this point in time you know
when we can have conversations on
twitter or facebook or like this about
these
these works that's really quite awesome
all right um
oh mark asked how does a conservative
catholic university admins respond to
someone teaching the grand inquisitor
do they see it as criticism of their
bureaucratic authority
so that's a great question
to begin with there's very few
conservative
universities as a matter of fact there's
very few catholic universities that call
themselves catholic universities
marquette just down the road prime
example of that
um you could walk around and other than
some statuaries and some crucifixes in
the classroom
there's no there's nothing to tell you
it's a catholic university because it's
lost that ethos generations ago
and it did so in large part through a
certain kind of conservativism that has
nothing to do with culture and has
everything to do with
business and making money you know
marquette's core
and this is the case for many catholic
colleges marquette's core curriculum has
been gutted
very little philosophy left very little
theology
very little even rhetoric and writing
and it's mostly oriented towards giving
kids who want to go into dentistry or
law
or business you know supply chain
management is one of the big majors
there these days
or get themselves a degree in psychology
or communications it's largely oriented
towards professional schools and towards
preparing people for the workplace and
all the catholic stuff is basically just
window dressing
you know um admins
admins know nothing about what's going
on
within classes because when we talk
about admins we're talking about like
you know the president
and the vice presidents
and the provost and the various deans
and assistant deans
unless something is brought to their
attention they don't have a clue
about what's being taught even shares
department chairs
rarely know what's going on
in any particular person's class unless
it's brought to their attention
this is and this is the case everywhere
unless you've got like a real butt in
ski
kind of micro manager administrator
this they don't know what's going on in
people's classes
and they they're not going to care if
you're teaching dostoevsky they probably
don't even remember what dostoevsky had
to say
most of these people are just business
types who
you know they had a veneer of you know
liberal education back in the day and
they don't remember
much of that so you know
um there's not a lot of worries about
that that sort of thing unless you
get drawn to somebody's attention like
you've got some
you know some uh intolerant student in
your classroom from the left or the
right
who you know writes an email and they're
like i can't believe that so-and-so is
teaching this you know
how can this go on in this institution
and then they might be like
hey academic freedom if you don't like
the class suck it and get out of here
go take another class or they might be
like oh well we need to crack down on
this sort of thing
totally random you know so there isn't
really
that sort of worry for the most part
again unless you get drawn to somebody's
attention and that takes people
doing doing work um
i i think that most people
in administration if they know anything
about the
the grand inquisitor it's probably
because they took an existentialism
class a long time ago or maybe apolly
uh poli sci class where it was brought
up and they it wouldn't really register
on their radar
the fact that you're teaching
dostoyevsky already like makes it
okay in their book because that's that's
classic literature right
unless they're worried about
decolonizing the curriculum
you know if they're one of those types
um
engaging in in that uh
practice crusade whatever we want to
call it
uh and then they might be like well you
know
that's that's you know to western or
something like that
but it's not going to get you in trouble
so
all right um waiter b says i've been
having the same
ideas myself about having to create a
new system of education but they should
be formed around a new civilizational
outlook
so the education reproduces the system i
mean but how are you going to get
anybody to
fund that or spread it or something like
that there isn't going to be a new
system
if there if there's going to be new
initiatives it's not going to be in
terms of a system
it's going to be in terms of doing
something here locally
with you know the possibility of
reaching people across the
internet and then trying to replicate
that in other places
we we inhabit an incredibly pluralistic
setting when it comes to education and
it's going to remain so
and it's going to remain you know the
only common elements are going to be the
bureaucratic parts of it like
accreditation and the notion of classes
being
um you know three carnegie hours
per per week uh 15 weeks or things like
that in order to get credit
but um i don't see prospects for
seizing control of the system like let's
say you became
secretary of education here in the
united states powerful position right
one of the cabinet could you
change american education even if you
didn't worry about the k-12 stuff you're
just focusing on college
and universities could you produce any
really significant systematic changes
probably not even with that amount of
power in part because we don't have a
system what marquette does is
maybe in line with in in terms of trends
what saint anselm's college in new
hampshire is doing in terms of gutting
the core
and pretending to be a catholic school
but each of them is a totally separate
entity and they do what they want to do
you know
what marquette does has nothing to do
with what uw milwaukee does has nothing
to do with what cardinal stritch
which is a franciscan university here in
milwaukee does
has nothing to do with what mount mary
college does has nothing to do with what
concordia a lutheran college
on the north side does all of these are
separate
institutions and
they're not they're not really a system
as such
so all right oliver says it's really
interesting that in the european schools
philosophy and critical thinking is a
mandatory subject in high school
yeah i mean it's interesting it's it's
not necessarily
effective um
i mean i'm glad that they're teaching
some philosophy but
you know having talked to plenty of
people who took those classes
they're kind of hit and miss um i mean
some of my
my stuff actually gets used for the
portuguese national curriculum
who study philosophy in 10th and 11th
grade
um but that doesn't mean that any kid
like i mean
i think about myself as a high schooler
right i spent more time probably
scribbling heavy metal stuff you know
like band logos and things like that on
the desk
i probably spent more time doing that or
sleeping than i did actually paying
attention in class
so you know i don't know that it makes
that big of a difference
um
let's see oliver says it's really
interesting to work in an international
high school and see how different
cultures approach this aspect of
pedagogy
yeah and even within the same culture
you can have a vast variety of
of approaches or responses right
parents can be like oh man i want my kid
to be
reading this stuff and exposed to great
ideas so they can have a freedom of mind
and you know be a contributing member of
society and other parents can be like
i want my kid to go to this school
because that's going to be a good
diploma to have and it's going to get
them into a good college and then
they're going to have a good job
other parents can be like i don't really
care what the hell my kid is doing i
just pay the money and it's nice for my
kid to be there out of my hair
and there's like all these different
possible
responses right um
so yeah let's see
oh here so here's an interesting
speculation
by byringen a new system will only come
after a catastrophic collapse sadly in
my view
yeah so this is a much bigger issue how
do we
how do we fundamentally change
systems or whatever passes as a system
for the better what what sort of
circumstances
would allow us to to do that crises
can uh sometimes afford that
um and so
yeah i think that i mean i i we we do
have some looming crises don't we i mean
we we are in the middle of an
environmental crisis
uh the stuff that's happening on the
west coast right now you know with the
massive
temperature spikes and it's its effects
on
agriculture which is going to affect the
entire food system
throughout the the americas um
perhaps the world itself that
is that's a particular crisis can you
use that to change education
i don't know but you could change you
could use it to change
some other things what would be the
factors that would allow you to change
education um
i mean we're also living through another
major crisis
promoted by the factors of
ai logistics um
robotics you know a lot of
jobs 20 years from now that we currently
have are are going to be gone
and we could be looking at something
like 25 to 50
unemployment here in the united states
and our traditional way of been doing
that is like well we'll train you for
new jobs and and by the way we'll give
you some money to go to college for
you know to get it to get a degree can
we really do that anymore
um that's that's another entire
discussion and
you know would you need somebody like
the grand inquisitor and his ilk
taking power to say okay we've got to
manage this
or can we can we rely on the tech elites
or
you know the politicians to figure out
the answers
for these sorts of things
all right roughly bumble writes do you
think if one of plato's republic
guardians became dissatisfied and then
disillusioned with a good divine well
here's a good question
he'd become something like the grand
inquisitor a cynical shell of his former
self
yeah i i certainly do i think that if
you had
um plato's republic i mean
think about how plato's republic depicts
the fall
of
[Music]
moving from one regime to the next one
more
corrupt than the next in republic book
eight
it's you move away from the aristocracy
that he originally has which by the way
is not the ideal city the ideal city is
actually the simple city
the city that plato's talking about from
you know
the middle of book two onward is
actually the city inflamed with lusts
and stuff like that
and so the you know the guardians and
the lesser guardians and the the crafts
people
that's already a screwed up city so you
move to more and more screwed up cities
and why because people want um
wealth they start hoarding it and um
and they they want honor and they they
lose sight of the rationality that's at
play
plato never this is really interesting
this is going to be a bit of a tangent
one of the things that i point out to my
students
when we're talking about republic book
four
is that you know plato talks about the
possibility of um
you know the three parts of the soul
being out of alignment with each other
and the most common problem is the
appetites the epithumia
the desires for sex you know
physical enjoyments getting drunk uh
making money all those sorts of things
those dominate
the soul the lower parts and then the
higher parts serve them right
and then there's another problem when
the the part of us that gets angry and
desires honor the thumbos
when that's the thing running the show
and the main problem with logos
the rational part is that it just
doesn't have enough power by itself to
coerce the appetites and it needs the
most to help out
but my students point out and i also
point out if they don't realize it that
maybe it could be pop become possible to
be
screwed up in the logic part and that's
still to dominate
you know and so maybe you could have
somebody who's like
these friggin guardians they get things
wrong all the time and they're not
actually like producing the great
society
i'm gonna figure out how to take power
from within
and
manage this and we can have some of
those
those smart dummies as figureheads but
i'm gonna run the show and maybe a few
of
the rest of us will run the show um from
the back end
um i think yeah that that would be a
story that that could be told
i think i think you can say that that is
something that we see in speculative
fiction
um but i i'm struggling
to think of exactly who
i mean so so okay so philip jose farmer
in the river world series some of the
ethicals
the people who are actually like
structuring everything and running the
show
revolt against each other um
and try to subvert it from within and it
actually leads to a big
big uh screw-up um
all right so i i think i lost the thread
here
there we go mark says what comparisons
would i draw between
prince mishkin and the idiot of the
great inquisitor
story um mishkin's character arc seems
like a parallel to what happens to
christ in some ways
well i mean there's a big difference in
that first of all
the idiot's a whole novel this is just a
little chapter christ doesn't say
anything
in the grand inquisitor chapter the only
thing he does
is some miracles loves the people and
then kisses the grand inquisitor
right whereas mishkin is is a main
character who's like
you know talking with all sorts of
people and
kind of bumbling around um
he's got some insight into human
psychology
uh he's christ-liking that he suffers
he's not he's not christ-like in that he
like does miracles or anything like that
or
you know radically fixes the whole the
whole thing or
i mean that does i guess the the real
question you could ask
is does michigan
bring people the other characters that
he's involved with does he bring them
freedom does he
raise their the problematic of their
freedom to a higher level
[Music]
and maybe the answer is yes in the case
of some of the characters
it's been a while since i've looked at
the idiot um
but maybe i need to go back to it so
all right uh gigga chad mesh sorry for
my poor phrasing and question thanks for
answering would you say dostoevsky's own
life exile seeing execution
what's the reference there there was a
mock execution that he was
uh part of for for being uh convicted as
a traitor
and then he was sent to siberia after
that that was a real kick in the pants
to him
had shaped his political views his
biography helpful for analysis yeah
biography is always helpful for for
analysis
not just for dostoevsky but for many
others but you
of course don't want to reduce um oh
you can reduce in second rate thinkers
they're ideas to
just biographical stuff but in the in in
the case of first-rate thinkers
biography is one factor that figures in
and and yeah i mean you can you can see
it in the development of his works right
he goes from being what at that time was
you know
sort of a progressive liberal
um uh along sort of european lines to
being this person who's got a
much darker deeper conception
of human nature and its problematics and
can
bring in characters develop characters
who
are so um different from each other
and yet so well drawn out that at a
certain point
um i think bok tina is right just as
with with shakespeare you cannot
identify
dostoevsky's voice with any one of his
characters um bach teen has this
wonderful book uh problems of
dostoevsky's poetics
that i would check out um
[Music]
columbus sometimes when people learn
something badly it makes them think they
understand and then treat something they
know it all about
therefore they can dismiss it yeah
dismiss it or like hold on to it like a
talisman right
um critical thinking is a great example
of this i don't know how many
people outside of philosophy use this
word critical thinking
to describe their classes and what their
what they're promoting in their students
and you
you look at their curriculum and you're
like this isn't critical thinking
um this might be teaching people to be a
little critical about things
but it's there's you know very little
about structure of argumentation
or understanding of biases and fallacies
or learning how to make and break an
argument or any any of that sort of
stuff
people yeah latch on to buzzwords
and um you know then they they
they think they know all about it um i
i posted an article today about you know
post-modernism what it is what it isn't
um there have been so many people in
recent years who have been like
and postmodernism is ruining everything
and you're like you don't have a clue
what post-modernism means you know
um so now it's critical race theory
right
every all these people on the right are
like critical race theory you know slash
my tires
it's destroying our culture and you're
like
what does it actually mean and they
they'll they'll give some definition
it's a [ __ ] definition
they don't know what they're talking
about and um
really what they're upset about is
teaching accurate information about
how race has worked out in our society
and we could go on and on and on about
about this sort of thing right
so you're right yeah people learn
something badly
and they are learning something right
but they are learning it badly
they think they understand it and then
they can treat it treat it as something
else just like you know people
read the grammar visitor all about like
and the government is not going to take
my freedom
and you're like that's that's not
exactly what the
the main thrust of this is here so
them you know raising your property tax
or
saying that you can't walk around with a
gun anywhere is not
the grand inquisitor taking away human
freedom
entirely but but people do that so
all right mark has a comment about
decolonization
i think dostoevsky's writing would
actually be interesting to incorporate a
lot of the environment of the story
seems to
deal with the tension in russia with
westernization or europeanization of its
culture and the effect that it has on
its society
seems a fruitful insight when it's
thinking of its impact elsewhere yeah
and so i'm going to go on a little bit
of a rant here
decolonization here in the united states
typically means we need to have less
white male authors and more
representatives from other
things right and white is understood
along the um sort of typical census
lines right
are you european in any way you're white
are you
middle eastern you're white you know
unless unless you get far
enough into the uh asian subcontinent
in which case you're asian right
so like a pakistani would be considered
asian
whereas an iranian would be considered
white and and this is just entirely
ridiculous
i mean uh so there's you know there's
quite a few people
that are calling for decolonization and
are doing so in crude and clumsy and
counterproductive ways
that said um what we do want to have
is a greater diversity of voices and
mark is entirely right that this
problematization
of european versus russian
this is not a white thing this is a
different kind of thing that was going
on throughout russian literature
i mean dostoyevsky is part of that
so is gogol so is um
these great you know 19th century
writers
it's a it's a problematic that extends
into the 20th century
with thinkers like lavshestoff right so
this is a really
yeah this is a really good insight we
need to
without turning it into the sort of a
typical american thing like well i'm
italian-american so therefore
you know that's my ethnicity or i'm
irish american instead we
think about it in terms of problematic
um ethnicities right
and where we draw lines and and you know
things like that
so yeah considering
not not in terms of the grand inquisitor
but in terms of dostoevsky's
other writings this problematic of well
do you want to become a westerner is
that part of becoming just one
big happy rationality like in the
underground man
or is there something that's that's
without getting all mystical the russian
uh approach to things
uh jacross the the white i feel
visual art isn't a major crisis guidance
is poor
at best through the university system uh
many teachers are validating their own
failed styles and objective teaching is
a rare blessing
so you could say that i suppose locally
but unless you've actually done like
some sort of study about
art schools or what's going on i would
be very suspect about these
these sweeping claims about teachers are
validating their own failed styles and
objective teaching as a rare blessing
um art has been in crisis the entire
20th century and
into the 21st century this is actually
nothing new
this has been going on for generations
and generations
and yet it seems to like churn away i
will tell you this
working at a school of art and design
that the biggest concerns that i see are
less conceptual
and more about the stranglehold that
financial elites have over the art world
because of you know all the auction and
you know the
buying and selling and the sort of star
system and stuff like that
um i don't see
you know i mean certainly the stuff that
you're saying in your
comment i don't see that happening at
milwaukee institute of art and design
uh might be happening at the art
institute in chicago i don't know
because i don't i don't
teach down there um
the biggest the biggest concerns are
really more like
um business and and finance co-opting
art
and making it very arbitrary who gets to
display and who doesn't get to display
so oh here's a very good question from
michael
what would you say to someone who wants
to read classic books in philosophy and
literature but who is intimidated by
them
so um this is a perennial issue
right and
when i think about this on the spot
right now there's being intimidated by
the books
but i'm willing to bet that for a lot of
people the intimidation is not
just the books themselves and the
authors themselves
it's an intimidation from other
people other readers other teachers of
the stuff
who will tell you you'll never
understand this you're not good enough
you're you're stupid you know or things
like that right
lurking in the background being
worried about being made fun of this is
the thing that keeps students from
raising their hand in class
and advancing an idea about the book
which is very often
on point um because they're worried
about what other people are going to say
that they're going to laugh at them
i think that's part of the the issue and
you know when you have those sort of
like
voices in the back your head there's
nothing that that says that you can't
say screw you to them
um it is tough though
right and there's
there's some legitimate reasons for
thinking that books like
brothers karamazov are going to be
difficult
dostoevsky is grappling with you know
major ideas that through the mouths of
his and thoughts of his characters
and it's also about a different time and
place so that presents certain problems
you know if you
read plato's symposium you're you're
being transported back into
fourth century greece bc
right and and a very different uh milieu
in which um sexuality is understood in
in ways and through categories that we
don't really um
usually typically look at it in our own
time and
even politics is being understood
differently so those are those are
factors that could make for
a bit of intimidation actually a lot of
intimidation
and i guess the thing that you could say
about that is
it's it's okay to feel intimidated that
by itself doesn't have to hold you back
from from reading and
the first time that you read you're
going to miss most of what's going on
and then you'll realize that the next
time that you read you know
and you'll realize that also through
talking with other people
who care about classic literature
and get excited about it and it's it's
okay
uh you don't have to jump from
you know bare beginner level to mastery
level or even intermediate
it's okay not to know everything it's
okay to
be confused by um parts
or to feel yourself out of your depth
that that's all right because that
doesn't keep you
from being able to keep working at it
right um what what keeps you from
continually working at it is some sort
of voice in the back your head that says
oh you suck you didn't get this right
away you're never gonna figure this out
and that's you know that's not um
an oracle that knows your future or
anything like that
um very often that's again the
reflection of
[ __ ] who've said assholish things to
us about literature
they could be professors they could be
parents they could be fellow students
but if you lend yourself to it
you will find the book does some of the
work after a while
that sounds a little confusing i i know
but um
so the long story short you it it you
know if you do feel intimidated that's
okay
you don't have to be intimidated and you
can you can keep working at it
um
all right uh let's see
just skipped a little bit
um
b says the man who was thursday versus
the grand inquisitor i don't
see a versus there what would be the
lines on which we would compare or
contrast them man
uh who was thursday was a great you know
chestertonian
novel this is a chapter from uh
the brothers karamazov um
all right mark says you you said you
usually teach do you see it
dostoevsky in an existentialism course
have you ever tried him in a christian
philosophy course how would you
incorporate him and
would you focus on his thought i've
never taught a christian philosophy
course
uh of course specifically on christian
philosophy
i think um that would be one of those
courses where it would be so difficult
the usual triage of like man i'd like to
teach this and this and this and i get
15 weeks and i don't know that that i
would actually have dostoevsky
in that because there's so many other
people to uh
to get to um
all right let's see here
a bunch of new comments just popped up
um kind of love about i think an
understanding of russian history and
orthodox theology is important for
understanding the great russian thinkers
of the 19th century
yeah yes and no um i would say in order
to understand gold gold you don't need
to really know much about
eastern orthodoxy it probably helps a
bit with dostoyevsky depending on which
novel you're reading
i don't think you actually need to know
much about it in order to understand
the possessed or the demons or you know
notes from the underground
it certainly does help given that one of
the characters
is you know essentially a postulant
right
uh to know it for for this book but i
don't i don't think you need to know an
awful lot about orthodox theology to
appreciate much
of russian literature um russian history
helps to some degree
um but you know
how much british history do you need to
know in order to appreciate chesterton
um not all that much
a lot of it will be supplied on the way
everything helps right but it's not it's
not a prerequisite i would say
mark says on the one hand i could see
the freedom that we're saved from is
like what sart would call bad
faith the inquisitor feeds us gives us a
role and then frees me from choice
yeah i mean like bad faith could be a
component in it it's it's actually like
a much
wider system that um
the inquisitor and his buddies are
projecting and trying to put into place
that like you know it's like a
totalitarian system in effect
and it doesn't necessarily it could be
totalitarian
in the sense of totalizing without
having like a totalitarian
um government like
you could think of this in terms of um
you know certain corporations
and their little portion of the world
and what they're trying to do with it
you know as being kind of similar all
these uh
ted style talks where you know a tech
guy gets up and he's like
we're gonna change everything for the
butter you know just put the power in
our hands
they're kind of like little grand
inquisitors aren't they um
all right connor says i want to see how
this connects to political theory
well we talked about that at the start
um you know
this has to do with the use of human
freedom and the grand inquisitor is
talking about political organization
that's
the third great temptation right so
um all right let's see
luke's has this goes back to the
question that
[Music]
was raised about um being intimidated by
michael
who asked about being intimidated by
philosophical and literary
works um
for me it's the idea i need to be an
expert in order to share my thoughts
with people
um just skipped a little bit with people
in a way that will benefit them fear
that i will
advise them foolishly um i mean you
could easily
deal with that by by preceding what
you're going to say to them with
i'm not an expert but here's my take you
know um
i i kind of i do understand that you
know this is part of what
people are always saying like why don't
you do you know videos on
chinese philosophy and i'm like listen i
teach it in class
but i'm not an expert on that and i'm
leery
of putting stuff out there as resources
for people that i'm not particularly
you know good at or versed in and i so i
understand that
that impulse but you you could frame it
in such a way that you don't have to be
an expert
to contribute um and that's that's in
part
how you how you improve and and get
better
um
let's see oh a little bit over time i'm
gonna kind of
bring this bring this to a close
[Music]
so here's a here's a good question
gig chad mesh asks if the grand
inquisitor revamped academia
if we do require a class of
intellectuals in the polis how would
classism snobbery or cast be abolished
um
i mean i don't i don't know that it
would be right
um classism is the idea
i guess that some classes are better
than others and in
that kind of organization some classes
are better than others right
uh snobbery i mean snobbery exists
pretty much every society and it's not
just intellectuals it's also pseudo
intellectuals who engage in that
caste um that depends on how you
organize your society right
so having a class of intellectuals
doesn't necessarily mean having a cast
of intellectuals right
analog tips is there any parallel
between the bread the grand inquisitor
offers and the covid restrictions put in
place by current states no there is no
parallel between that
that's that's uh kind of a funny thing
to to bring up i mean
i've talked about this with other people
if if this were like 20 years ago
um when i was younger and the culture i
remember
the kind of coveted restrictions that we
had people would have accepted them
it's because we have this toxic emphasis
on
mushroom and individuality and you know
that the republican party
here in the states and similar parties
and other places have exploited
um where people are like really
delusional about this kind of stuff
that people view it as a massive
infringement of their freedom
you know we're in some serious problems
because of that
but that's a whole other uh
thing to talk about i think in some
other time let me see if there was
something else that i
saw um okay so mark
says over a course of comments
coming back to the grand inquisitor
jesus's death was to free us from sin so
we're free to try to earn our own
salvation
free from trying to uh both alleviate
responsibility for me jesus respects the
freedom of the will
yeah you can say not just his death but
his life and his teachings too
right um that's part of what what ivan
is having the grand inquisitor credit
jesus with he's like
you know you came here and you just made
things more
complicated for everybody uh let me see
if i can find the actual
here we go um instead of taking over
men's freedom you increased it and
forever burdened the kingdom of the
human soul with its torments
you desire the free love of human beings
that they should follow you freely
seduced and captivated by you instead of
the firm
ancient law human beings had to decide
for themselves with a free heart what is
good
and evil having only your image
before them as a guide did it not occur
to you they would eventually reject and
dispute even your image and your truth
if they were oppressed by so terrible a
burden has freedom of choice that is
what the inquisitor is saying the
fundamental problem is and and now you
know to go back to the question about
like christian philosophy one of the key
ideas that came out in the christian
philosophy debates is that
christianity through its culture
intellectual life practices
put new ideas and experiences on the
table that then philosophy
in its rational workings can take unpack
unfold
this would be one of them the nature of
human freedom the
the capacity to determine our own wills
how to live up to a model a very
difficult model both
displayed and also taught like for
example in the sermon
on the mount those are some really
interesting
things that would connect back to this
brother
brothers karamazov chapter
so good time to close things up i got a
lot of work i got to do on my online
classes
for the summer they are starting uh in
my intro to philosophy class plato's
symposium
this coming week um so i've got a
knock off and good good discussion as
always we'll do another one of these
next month haven't decided what the
topic will be yet but i'll be posting
that
you know like in the next week or so
you'll see it in um
in the video channel um thanks to
everybody for their
questions and comments and i'll see you
in some other online events